[Music]
cancer big thing big thing cancer right
that's pretty scary but you can prevent
cancer 100% by again avoiding the bad
things prevention is always easier it's
kind of like putting oil in your car
before the engine burns up you put it on
your car before the engine burns up you
don't wait until the engine burns up to
see well let's put a little oil in there
don't get all crazy about trying to get
healed when you can prevent it it's real
simple
okay much cheaper much less painful and
you'll add 25 healthier years your life
okay next cat-scans which doctors will
tell you harmless actually have 400%
more radiation than they used to think
you had twenty-nine thousand new cancer
patients every year of which half 14,500
died after just one cat scan you know
you can get an ultrasound a high
definition ultrasound for 50 bucks tell
you the same information they can see
the valves in the pea-sized heart of a
little embryo human embryo it's just a
month old that high-definition
ultrasound there's no radiation to it no
risk cost 50 bucks that can't scan cost
4000 next high fiber diets do not cut
colon cancer risk as another old myth
high fiber diets do not cook cut colon
cancer risk this was a study on on
90,000 nurses and 50,000 male doctors
over a 20-year period the Harvard Nurses
Health Study there was no problem I mean
just high fiber guys didn't help got the
same rate of cancer from high fiber ties
to low fiber diets but when you ate a
high fiber diet because of the risk of
celiac disease because fiber is usually
wheat gluten or oat bran or something
like that it increases your risk of
diabetes and heart disease and stroke
and other stuff don't eat high fiber
diets there is no benefit in fact
there's unintended consequences that are
not nice okay next
look at that
fat doesn't increase your risk of breast
cancer you can actually eat 90 percent
of your calories from fat and as long as
you don't fry it next this is a another
study only 15 years old
I think it's Lu 15 years Harvard Nurses
Health Study 90,000 nurses you take a
high-end multivitamin like our mighty 19
knot of one-a-day centrum or something
like that that won't work because it
only has like 32 is the mighty 32
instead of the mighty 90 you take the
mighty 90 this reduces your risk of
colon cancer by 75% are there any drugs
that will do that
no next let's see here
study finds very well-done meat linked
to breast cancer you can reduce your
risk of breast cancer ladies by 462
percent by eating your meat cooked
medium or medium rare if you cook your
meat very well-done where it's burnt
where the fat is burnt tastes good but
the killer and the devil comes in many
guises including burnt fat I mean think
about it you know Hellfire and burnt
I mean that's the devil sense of humor
there okay next we've known about
selenium being able to prevent and cheer
certain types of cancer since 1912 since
1912 we've known this and I had to sue
the FDA I sued the FDA and won in
federal court they appealed and I beat
him in the appellate court and then they
appealed and they signed off on the
steps of the US Supreme Court for me be
able to say that the tracer no selenium
can prevent certain types of cancer the
trace mill selenium can help your body
make certain anti-cancer substances just
to say those simple things I had to sue
him three times in federal courts but
the truth want out there in that case
we're able to beat the FDA to death on
that one thank you okay next this is
just another thing on selenium is a big
study out of the University of Arizona
just taking 200 micrograms of selenium
1/5 of a milligram of selenium it'll
reduce your risk of prostate cancer men
by 69% colorectal cancer both genders by
64% lung cancer with you smoke or not by
39% anybody who smokes and doesn't take
the mighty 90 with a little extra
selenium is foolish aren't they now I
can guarantee you ladies if you take the
mighty 90 you will never get prostate
cancer I can guarantee you that okay
next next oh I love this one
arsenic can prevent and cure certain
types of leukemia arsenic
we've known as essential nutrient
necessary to prevent certain types of
cancer certain types of leukemia since
1947 and that funny okay next okay
preventing cancer is very easy once you
get it it's a full-time job
to treat it as a chronic disease you can
add five or ten or fifteen or twenty or
thirty years to your life when you have
cancer but you're gonna be working 24/7
for the rest of your life it's much
better to prevent it that way you have a
life right it's much better proud but we
can work with you if you do have it
you're salvageable through God's grace